sehr geehrter herr präsident liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen das
bundesverfassungsgericht hat mit seiner
entscheidung vom februar 2020
ausdrücklich das recht auf
selbstbestimmtes sterben als ausdruck
persönlicher
autonomie anerkannt und dieses recht
umfasst auch die freiheit hier für hilfe
in anspruch zu nehmen von dritten eine
solche freier entscheidung dem eigenen
leben ein ende zu setzen steht also
jedem menschen zu sie ist zu
respektieren
dennoch darf selbsttötung nicht zum
gesellschaftlichen normalfall werden und
suizid assistenz nicht zu einer
gewöhnlichen dienstleistung
in unserem staat haben wir die achtung
der würde des menschen zum leitmotiv
unseres grundgesetzes gemacht und alle
gewählten
repräsentantinnen und repräsentanten und
institutionen haben den auftrag die
unversehrtheit menschlichen lebens zu
schützen und darum gibt es
regelungsbedarf ja es muss für
sterbewillige die sich in der letzten
phase einer unheilbaren krankheit
befinden möglich sein ohne große hürden
hilfe zur suizid assistenz zu erhalten
um leiden nicht unnötig zu verlängern
und auch das wollen wir gewährleisten
aber gleichzeitig braucht es ein
abgestuftes und ausgewogenes
schutzkonzept dass die autonomie und
frei verantwortlichkeit tatsächlich
gewährleistet
darum schlagen wir mit unserem gesetz
zur strafbarkeit der geschäftsmäßigen
hilfe zur selbsttötung und zur
sicherstellung der frei
verantwortlichkeit der entscheidung zur
selbsttötung vor den assistierten
zieht unter bedingungen zu ermöglichen
ihn aber nicht zu fördern und das können
wir erreichen durch ein werbeverbot für
die suizid assistenz ja das erschrecken
viele menschen im lauf ihres lebens eine
suizidale krise haben hierfür gibt es
vielfältige ursachen die probleme im
kontext der eigenen lebenssituation
soziale notlagen oder auch psychische
erkrankung in den allermeisten dieser
fälle handelt es sich um eine
veränderbare
krisensituation und da
und da kann schnelle
diskriminierungsfreie und
unbürokratische hilfe schon den
entscheidenden unterschied machen und
den sterbewunsch verändern aus diesem
grund ergänzen wir den gesetzentwurf um
eine initiative zur stärkung der
suizidprävention
ich bin fest davon überzeugt
suizid darf keine gesellschaftlich
akzeptierte antwort auf soziale nöte
existenzsorgen oder einsamkeit sein er
muss die seltsam seltene ausnahme
bleiben
der suizid assistenz anbietet muss darum
nach klaren regeln sicherstellen dass
dieser wunsch frei verantwortlich ohne
druck von dritten geäußert wird und
dauerhaft ist schließlich geht es um
eine unumkehrbare entscheidungen
und darum muss menschen und mit
sterbewunsch zunächst der raum eröffnet
werden den eigenen entschluss sorgfältig
zu reflektieren
womöglich eine andere perspektive
einzunehmen und lebensmut und
lebenswillen zurückzugewinnen und das
sage ich ausdrücklich als
sozialpolitikerin die sich seit jahren
für eine menschenwürdige pflege für eine
flächendeckende gute versorgung durch
hospiz und palliativmedizin und für
tragfähiger beratungs und welche
strukturen einsetzt wohl wissend dass
das heute noch nicht ausreichend ist
lassen sie uns heute und im weiteren
parlamentarischen verfahren intensiv und
respektvoll über die vorliegenden
gesetzentwürfe beraten ich werbe um
unterstützung für unseren gesetzentwurf
weil ich davon überzeugt bin dass wir
damit eine balance zwischen den
rechtsgütern leben und selbstbestimmung
herstellen wir fördern flächendeckende
und niedrigschwellige angebote zur
suizidprävention aber gleichzeitig
schaffen wir hohe hürden für
geschäftsmäßige suizid assistenz denn
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen sterben
ist nicht leicht den tod herbeizuführen
muss schwerer sein vielen dank
drei gesetzentwürfe liegen vorher zur
ersten beratung sind alle von
fraktionsübergreifenden gruppen
erarbeitet worden denn in solchen
ethisch schwierigen fragen da hebt der
bundestag gewöhnlich die den
fraktionszwang auf alle drei sehen
beratungspflichten schutzfristen und ein
vier augen prinzip vor der zentrale
unterschied bei dem den auch heike
behrens unterstützt ist dass die
suizidhilfe weiter über das strafrecht
geregelt werden soll jetzt thomas seitz
für die afg
zugleich millionen wähler das ist keine
sternstunde des parlamentarismus aber
zur sache die suizidbeihilfe braucht
eine regelung die selbstbestimmte
sterben ermöglicht den notwendigen
schutz woher aber gruppen dazu gehören
minderjährige genauso wie psychisch
angeschlagene menschen
gewährleistet und vor missbrauch schützt
hierzu braucht es die mitwirkung
qualifizierter berufsträger die
zwangsläufig geschäftsmäßig handeln denn
damit ist allein eine auf wiederholung
angelegte tätigkeit gemeint es geht
nicht um die frage der entgeltlichkeit
wobei es auch nicht unredlich ist als
berufsträger durch die mitwirkung an
einem 3 bestimmten suizid geld zu
verdienen
denn das ist notwendig damit menschen in
würde von uns gehen können diesen
ansprüchen genügt leider keiner der drei
gesetzesentwürfe ich beginne mit
drucksache 904 ein antrag der mehr
verhinderungs lösung ist denn
ermöglichung lösung das wesen autonomie
wird völlig verkannt wenn jede
geschäftsmäßige förderung der
selbsttötung für tatbestands mäßig also
strafbar erklärt wird die idee eines
multiprofessionellen
beratungsgesprächs ist ohne
institutionelle verankerung und
gesicherte finanzierung völlig
unpraktikabel und eine zeitspanne von
zwei monaten zwischen netzer
untersuchungen und suizid ist
realitätsfremd vor dem
bundesverfassungsgericht haben
betroffene eindrucksvoll geschildert wie
erste gewissheit das eigene leben
jederzeit beenden zu können in die kraft
gegeben hat ihr schicksal über jahre
auszuhalten die rund 60 unterzeichner
aus den regierungsfraktionen frage ich
wie sie den wertungswiderspruch
rechtfertigen wenn sie folien § 209 10 a
verteufeln und jetzt als vorbild für ein
neues werbeverbot heranziehen ist das
heuchelei oder schizophrenie die beiden
anderen gesetzentwürfe kranken am
schutzkonzept bei drucksache 2293 sollen
beratungsstellen maßgeblich sein die in
erster linie mit ehrenamtlichen besetzt
sind eine zwingende ärztliche
beteiligung in den beratungsstellen ist
nicht vorgeschrieben damit lassen sich
das fehlen von willens mängeln und die
freiheit von äußere beeinflussung nicht
wieder zusammen feststellen bei grob
sache 23 32 ist zunächst schutz
minderjähriger völlig unzureichend
ausgestaltet und auch im übrigen fehlt
es an kontrolle und erinnert eher an das
lästige abhaken einer unvollständigen
checkliste ich verstehe nicht warum kein
entwurf die suizid assistenz in
anlehnung zur unterbringung und
betreuung im bgb und vfg regelt sowie
betreuungs richter beraten durch
sachverständige über gefährliche heil
maßnahmen freiheitsentziehung oder
zwangsbehandlung entscheiden kann man
ihnen auch die feststellung übertragen
dass ein suizid wunsch frei von willens
mängeln und hinreichend gefestigt ist
und dieser feststellungsbeschluss ist
dann die grundlage für die abgabe eines
tödlich wirkenden medikaments der antrag
zur suizidprävention ist selbst reden zu
begrüßen vielen dank
die afg abgeordnete thomas zeitz
schließt sich also keinem der
vorliegenden anträge gesetzentwürfe an
die nächste rednerin ist eine der
initiatorinnen eines der gesetzentwürfe
katrin heiligen klar ist dass
und sie wird ihren gesetzentwurf noch
einmal erläutern und begründen
ehrlich gesagt ein thema das mir angst
macht schon seit ich ein kleines kind
bin tut es das ich kann mir das
irgendwie ganz vorstellen nicht mehr da
sein auf dieser welt wo dann ich weiß
nicht wie es ihnen geht vielleicht
genauso vielleicht ganz anders wir reden
ja alle kaum darüber meist nur mit nahen
angehörigen
ich glaube das sollten wir ändern ich
habe aus den gesprächen die ich geführt
habe das gefühl dass sich die emotionen
beim gedanken an den eigenen tod mit dem
alter und mit krankheit ändern meine
großmutter zu der ich ein sehr enges
verhältnis hatte vermittelte mir immer
das gefühl das ist schon okay ist wenn
es soweit ist viele haben auch gar keine
angst vor dem tod selbst
sondern vor den umständen unter denen
vor schmerzen davor an geräten zu hängen
vor kontrollverlust und ich kann es auch
ganz gut verstehen dass man vor allen
dingen wenn man sowieso weiß dass das
leben ein ende nimmt und für sich auch
keine lebensqualität mehr empfindet dass
man es dann auch selbst beenden möchte
dass man auch in einer solchen situation
selbstbestimmt sein möchte vielleicht im
kreise seiner angehört hingehen will
meine damen und herren ich bin unfassbar
dankbar dass wir in einem land leben in
dem von verfassung wegen jedem diese
möglichkeit gegeben ist in dem ist
grundgesetzlich für einen
grundgesetzlich verbürgte recht auf
selbstbestimmtes sterben gibt das jedem
ermöglicht gerade in diesen besonderen
letzten lebens moment so weit ist die
körperlichen umstände erlauben so wie er
ist individuell als würde voll empfindet
zu gestalten und ich finde wir müssen
dieses recht auf selbstbestimmte sterben
auf ernst nehmen wenn wir das tun dann
ist es doch geradezu widersinnig und
unmenschlich dass wir menschen in
unserem land ihr leben selbstbestimmt
enden möchten keinen zugang zu den
geeigneten
medikamenten zur selbsttötung
ermöglichen das müssen wir ändern
wir müssen selbst bestimmen wandelnden
erwachsenen die möglichkeit geben nach
einer entsprechenden umfassenden
beratung einer beratungsstelle über
handlungsalternativen
auch eine möglichkeit zur verschreibung
eines tödlichen medikaments zu erhalten
und weil einige uns da immer wieder
versuchen bewusst falsch zu verstehen
ich möchte dass wir betroffenen in den
beratungsstellen jede helfende hand
reichen
in die möglichkeit geben nach jedem
strohhalm zu greifen muss beratung ist
die beste prävention
wenn sie sich aber dafür entscheiden
gehen zu wollen dürfen sind wir sie auch
dann nicht alleine das ohne erhobenen
zeigefinger und ohne ihnen das gefühl zu
vermitteln sie tun etwas unrechtes das
haben das haben menschen in solchen
situationen nicht verdient sie haben
gesellschaftliche geborgenheit verdient
unser höchster respekt sollte deshalb
auch menschen gelten die bereit sind
sterbewillige auf ihrem letzten weg zu
begleiten und ihnen sogar behilflich zu
sein das ist nicht leicht das kann nicht
jeder
vielfach sind es angehörige die ihre
eigenen gefühle ihren unbedingten wunsch
den geliebten menschen so lange wie
möglich bei sich zu behalten
zurückstellen weil sie den betroffenen
sein selbstbestimmtes endes ermöglichen
wollen und ich will ehrlich sein mir
läuft es bei dem gedanken dass wir diese
menschen wenn die gruppe castellucci
etwa eine mehrheit fände wieder mit
einem neuen straftatbestand bedrohen
könnten reis kalt den rücken haut denn
verehrte unterstützer des entsprechenden
gesetzentwurfs
sie stellen ja die leistung von
suizidhilfe ganz grundsätzlich wieder
unter strafe sie machen die ausübung
eines grundgesetzlich verbürgten rechts
zum kasus eines straftatbestandes und
sogar angehörige machen sich bei ihm
jedenfalls wenn sie mehrere ihnen
nahestehende menschen haben vater und
mutter den sie sich vorstellen können zu
helfen wieder strafbar wie beim
vormaligen paragrafen so nazis in deren
verfassungswidrigkeit das
bundesverfassungsgericht der
festgestellt hat wird sich kaum mehr
jemand trauen zu helfen alter wein in
neuen schläuchen und die aufnahmen die
sie nominell vorsehen sind so eng dass
betroffene doch wieder wenn sie sich
leisten können ins ausland gehen oder
sich auf total suizide verwiesen sehen
das dürfen wir den menschen nicht an tut
mein appell fallen wir nicht in die zeit
des paragrafen zu 17 strafgesetzbuch
zurück sprechen wir mehr miteinander
auch über das lebensende helfen wir
menschen im leben akzeptieren wir selbst
bestimmte frei verantwortlichen
entscheidungen vielen dank und daher hat
katrin helling klar und eine gruppe um
sie drum herum einen gesetzentwurf
vorgelegt der sozusagen das recht auf
suizid assistenz nach beratung
festschreiben will jetzt führen wir
einen vertreter des dritten antrages das
ist der antrag rund um renate künast da
geht es vor allem darum dass in einer
medizinische notlage ärzte medikamente
zu für den suizid verschreiben können
welches das bundesverfassungsgericht in
seinem urteil vom 26
februar 2020 abgeleitet hat geht es
nicht um individuelle wertvorstellung es
geht nicht um eine meinung für oder
gegen die suizidhilfe sondern es geht um
ein grundrecht ein grundrecht welches
das verfassungsgericht aus dem
allgemeinen persönlichkeitsrecht
abgeleitet hat ein grundrecht bei dem
die selbstbestimmung des oder der
einzelnen im zentrum steht und ein
grundrecht so ehrlich müssen wir hier
sein welches aktuell nicht ausreichend
geschützt wird ich verstehe dass
menschen sich in dieser debatte schwer
tun sie emotional führen oder das
ergebnis des urteils des
verfassungsgerichts nicht für sich
gelten lassen möchten aber wir beraten
hier und heute über nichts weniger als
die frage wie wir in diesem land ein
grundrecht schützen und machen wir uns
nichts vor die beihilfe zur selbsttötung
findet statt jetzt in diesem moment in
rechtlichen grauzonen ohne die nötige
klarheit ohne die klarheit darüber wie
betroffene und behandelnde ärzte nun
ärzte konkret geschützt werden und wenn
wir uns im sinne des
bundesverfassungsgerichts anschauen das
ist die entscheidung des einzelnen ist
entsprechend dem eigenen verständnis von
lebensqualität und sinnhaftigkeit der
eigenen existenz dem leben ein ende zu
setzen dann meine damen und herren
können wir diesen zustand so nicht
belassen und deswegen habe ich gemeinsam
mit den kolleginnen und kollegen renate
künast katja keul nina scheer etwa
franke und vielen anderen diesen
gesetzentwurf eingebracht um diese
rechts lücke zu schließen wir wollen mit
unserem gesetz zum schutz des
selbstbestimmten sterbens den zugang zur
natrium-pentobarbital unter
sicherstellung der kriterien für einen
autonomen dauerhaften und ernsthaften
sterbewunsch ohne einflussnahme dritter
regeln dafür sehen wir ein allgemeines
verfahren es beginnt mit einem antrag an
eine nach landesrecht zuständigen
behörde anschließend folgen zwei
beratungstermin im abstand von
mindestens zwei monaten wo im zentrum
der wert des menschenlebens steht die
den zweck haben die dauerhaftigkeit die
ernsthaftigkeit den freien willen dieser
entscheidung festzustellen und
anschließend folgt eben beide jahren die
bescheinigung auf herausgabe von natrium
pentobarbital
anders handhaben wie es bei menschen
medizinische notlage aus dem grund dass
wir da die prozessuale notwendigkeit
sehen dass sie ohnehin im
gesundheitssystem sind diese
entscheidung auch dort zu treffen
was aber jetzt der unterschied zwischen
unserem und den anderen beiden
gesetzentwürfe
fangen wir einmal an mit dem gerade von
kollegen hängen klar vorgestellten
suizidhilfe gesetz ich glaube die haben
einige gemeinsamkeiten aber der größte
unterschied ist zum einen die zeitspanne
im allgemeinen verfahren sehen wir
mindestens zwei monate vor um die
dauerhaftigkeit und ernsthaftigkeit
gewährleisten zu können und die frage
wer denn die kontrolle in ihrem system
übernimmt die frage wer in diesem land
grundrecht geschützt wir sagen ist es
aufgabe des staates und deswegen
schalten wir diese behörde ein im
anderen entwurf sind es private also
ärztinnen und ärzte die diese
entscheidung zu tragen viel größere
differenzen aber gibt es zum entwurf des
neuen § 217 stgb von kollege castellucci
und andere wir müssen noch einmal
festhalten dass grundsätzlich in diesem
land gilt dass der staat rechte dann
einschränken darf wenn er dafür eine
grundlage hat und eine abwägung
getroffen hat der vorliegende entwurf so
wie man liest kehrt das aber um man muss
eine rechtfertigung haben um sein
grundrecht in anspruch zu nehmen und man
muss sich eben rechtfertigen rechte in
anspruch zu nehmen diese umkehr ist doch
eine abweichung von unserer immer da
gewesenen grundrechtes thema
und wenn wir uns ein leitsatz
bundesverfassungsgerichts anschauen wenn
die rechtsordnung bestimmte für die
autonomie gefährliche formen der
suizidhilfe unter strafe stellt das
heißt es doch klar dass das schiff die
autonomie sein muss es ist doch klar
dass es hier darum geht diese autonomie
zu ermöglichen die entscheidung und den
suizid zu ermöglichen und liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen der strafrecht
ist der gänzlich falsche ort die
autonomie zu gewährleisten
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen ich werde
hier ganz ehrlich gar nicht dafür dass
sie sich alle unserem antrag anschließen
denn darum gibt es diese entscheidung
die wird gemeinsam alle gemeinsam zu
treffen haben ist für einige eine tiefe
persönliche sie ist eine entscheidung
frei von partei und fraktions meinung
und deswegen bitte ich sie um vor allen
dingen eins setzen sie sich mit der im
zentrum stehenden frage auseinander wie
wollen wir in diesem land das grundrecht
auf selbstbestimmtes sterben schützen
vielen dank
lukas panne war dass er unterstützt den
antrag und um die gruppe renate künast
der im moment was du das meinungsbild
anbelangt das bekannt ist die wenigsten
unterstützer die meisten unterstützer
bislang hat der entwurf und um lars
castellucci den auch patrick schnieder
der nächste redner unterstützt
geholfen werden
nach der breiten und konstruktiven
debatte die wir im jahr 2015
geführt haben müssen uns heute erneut
mit dieser frage beschäftigen wenn auch
unter anderen vorzeichen das
bundesverfassungsgericht hat sogar zwei
jahren entschieden dass das allgemeine
persönlichkeitsrecht als ausdruck
persönliche autonomie auch das recht auf
selbstbestimmtes sterben umfasst hier
für die hilfe dritter rechtmäßig ist bis
2015 beschlossene verbot der
geschäftsmäßigen sterbehilfe wurde damit
gekippt
zugleich nach karlsruhe in seiner
entscheidung deutlich dass die regelung
der suizid assistenz sich im
spannungsfeld von
selbstbestimmungsrecht und lebensschutz
als staatliche aufgabe bewegt der
gesetzgeber daher die möglichkeit zur
regulierung der sterbehilfe unter
bestimmten voraussetzungen
weiterhin hat es geht also um zwei
widerstreitende rechtsgüter das
bundesverfassungsgericht hat mit seiner
entscheidung nicht nur ein neues
grundrecht das recht auf
selbstbestimmtes sterben schaffen
sondern stellt den gesetzgeber
zugleich vor die aufgabe wieder einen
ausgleich zu schaffen zwischen
selbstbestimmungsrecht und
lebensschutz derzeit besteht eine
schieflage zwischen den beiden
rechtsgüter dass beispielsweise keine
regelungen gibt die sicherstellen dass
die betroffenen ihre entscheidung
freiwillig und ohne druck von außen
treffen
der vorliegende gesetzentwurf zur
strafbarkeit der geschäftsmäßige
sterbehilfe legt hier für einen gut
austarierten kompromiss vor
um das hohe leben rechtsgut leben zu
schützen sieht der entwurf vor die
geschäftsmäßige sterbehilfe
grundsätzlich wieder unter strafe zu
stellen
angesichts des hohen rangs den unsere
verfassung dem leben beim ist ist es
legitim zu mitteln des strafrechts zu
greifen um leben zu schützen
ich halte das für einen ganz wichtigen
punkt um den see hat wirklich sichtbar
um deutlich zu machen und ich will ja
klar stellen sowohl gegenüber meinem
vorredner wie gegenüber der kollegin
helen es geht hier um geschäftsmäßige
staatsbeihilfen es geht nicht um die
beihilfe zum suizid schlechthin die ist
und bleibt in der aktualität zur
haupttat immer straffrei in dem seit das
normalen fällen es geht um die
geschäftsmäßige mit super hilfe und die
angst davor dass über eine
normalisierung dieses angebots in der
gesellschaft und den druck den ältere
kranke menschen empfinden mögen das als
normales mittel empfinden um ihr leben
zu beenden und das wollen wir verhindern
und deshalb auch das rechtsgut so hoch
zu hängen und mit einer strafbarkeit
einer grundsätzlich strafbarkeit im
rahmen der geschäftsmäßigen sozialhilfe
zu versehen
darüber hinaus ist es im sinne des
lebensschutzes nicht zuletzt die aufgabe
des staates dieser normalisierung oder
förderung der suizid assistenz in der
öffentlichkeit oder in der
gesellschaftlichen debatte
entgegenzutreten und weil uns das
grundsätzlich ein besonderes anliegen
ist es auch folgerichtig dass mit einem
werbeverbot für die hilfe zur
selbsttötung zu versehen
zugleich war es aber auch die
initiatoren und oder zeichnern wichtig
die vorgaben des
bundesverfassungsgerichts einzuhalten
und natürlich respektieren und
akzeptieren wir das dort
herausgehobene recht auf
selbstbestimmtes sterben
und das im gleichen maße zu würdigen wie
den lebensschutz und da darf ich
verweisen auf das dass die kollegin
während sehr treffend die ja ausgeführt
hat das schutzkonzept dass wir in diesem
gesetzentwurf
vorgesehen haben und das wird diesem
anspruch sicherlich
gerecht
wir wissen allerdings auch durch die
studienlage durch zahlreiche berichte
von betroffenen von angehörigen von
ärzten von fliegen dass suizid wünsche
sehr volatil sind dass sie oft einer
situation entspringen dass sie
schon wieder aufhören wenn der
betroffene eine perspektive märkte nicht
mehr das gefühl hat allein gelassen zu
sein denn er hilfen in aussicht gestellt
bekommt wenn sein aktives leiden
gemindert haben deshalb ist genauso
wichtig wie das schutzkonzept die
vorschläge zur stärkung der
suizidprävention und ich glaube dem kann
sich eigentlich jeder in diesem hause
hier anschließen wir mit diesem
gesetzentwurf verbunden haben also meine
sehr geehrten damen und herren innerhalb
der vom bundesverfassungsgericht
vorgegebenen grenzen dem daraus
resultierenden status quo und im
vergleich zu den übrigen vorliegenden
initiativen mag dieser vorschlag den
einen zu restriktiv erscheinen gemessen
am christlichen menschenbild und der
entscheidung die wir 2015 getroffen
haben ist der anderen vermutlich zu weit
gehen ich glaube die stärke ist diese
unterschiedlichen sichtweisen
gleichermaßen zu würdigen und in den
grenzen des
bundesverfassungsgerichts zu bleiben und
in der kombination mit dem gesetzentwurf
zur prävention das als ganzes gesehen
wie eine runde sache
des entwurf und die gruppe castellucci
und andere der eben vorsieht dass die
geschäftsmäßige förderung der
selbsttötung grundsätzlich strafbar sein
soll allerdings mit ausnahmen wenn der
mensch volljährig einsichtsfähig und
sich beraten lassen
das werbeverbot für abtreibung wird
gestrichen und nun gewerbliche
suizidbeihilfe beides in einem
vormittags ich finde dass es ein symbol
es geht um die fundamente unserer
christlich-abendländischen unseres
christlich abendländischen
menschenbildes jeder suizid ist eine
menschliche und eine soziale katastrophe
er betrifft nicht nur den menschen der
geht sondern er betrifft auch die
menschen die er zurücklässt wie tief und
wie hart die getroffen werden das
belegen daten analysen aus schweden
suizide 10 suizide nach sich bei dem
suizid eines familienangehörigen steigt
die gefahr für seine angehörigen auf
suizid um das achtfache und bei den
kollegen am arbeitsplatz um das
dreieinhalbfache
die ziele sind nicht nur eine
individuelle
katastrophe sondern auch eine
gesellschaftliche tragödie
zieht gefährdete menschen werden nach
meiner ansicht im stich gelassen in die
man ihm natrium-pentobarbital
gibt um sich zu töten so wie es der
antrag von renate künast vorsieht solche
angebote schaffen davon bin ich
überzeugt nachfrage und vergrößern das
leid die legalisierung der
suizidbeihilfe wird menschenleben kosten
wir werden so künftig mehr suizide haben
die suizidrate wird steigen und sie wird
höher sein als in ländern die diese
regelungen nicht haben ich danke daher
den kollegen des gruppenantrags
suizidprävention dass sie diese gefahr
zu klar benennen von 182 ländern haben
140 länder in der welt eine niedrigere
suizidrate als deutschland die meisten
dieser länder sind sehr viel ärmer als
wir aber bei ihnen spielen regionen
heimat und auch familien eine größere
rolle als bei uns der verlust von
bindung von kultur und ja ich glaube
auch von glauben macht die menschen und
glücklicher und kraft los als antwort
auf diese kulturelle krise brauchen wir
eine kultur des lebens nicht hilfe zum
sterben sondern hilfe zum leben vielen
dank
vielen dank frau kollegin beatrix von
storch war das für die afg fraktion
anders darauf hinweisen dass ich das für
unverhältnismäßig hält während einer
laufenden debatte den kollegen kollegen
des hauses mit vertretern der regierung
auf der regierungsbank gespräche führen
das sieht nicht nur gut aus was
missachtet auch die notwendige
aufmerksamkeit die man im regen ein
sessel ihnen unter umständen in seinen
ausführungen nicht teilt das gilt für
alle beteiligten nicht wäre eine debatte
kann man draußen sich unterhalten aber
nicht optisch sichtbar hier im haus
kollegen mit der regierungsbank nächster
redner ist der kollege pascal kober
gruppe kassel
oktober unterstützt den antrag um die
gruppe rund um castellucci also dass
dieses verbot der geschäftsmäßigen
suizid assistenz liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen
leben ist immer ein leben in beziehungen
und so ist auch das eigene sterben immer
auch ein sterben inmitten des
geschlechtes der beziehungen in denen
wir im leben stehen und deshalb möchte
ich unsere aufmerksamkeit auch auf die
situation von angehörigen von
sterbewilligen richten deren leben vom
sterbewunsch und vom tod ihres
sterbewilligen angehörigen berührt und
betroffen ist
als seelsorger habe ich schon einige
familien von suizidenten begleitet
fachleute gehen im schnitt von sechs
personen aus deren leben durch den
suizid eines nahen angehörigen betroffen
wie aber muss sagen tief getroffen wird
es sind neben dem schmerzhaften verlust
unter fragen nach dem warum
sehr häufig auch die fragen nach eigener
schuld und eigenen versagen die
angehörige lange zeit quälen können
es geht um menschen die ihre partnerin
ihren partner verlieren es geht um
eltern die ihre tochter und ihren sohn
verlieren es geht um kinder die vater
oder mutter verlieren geschwister die
schwester oder bruder verlieren
wenn ich mit bürgerinnen und bürger über
sterbehilfe rede dann begegnen wir
häufig die sorge vor gesundheitlich
ausweglosen situationen die mit einem
schmerzhaften von hilflosigkeit
geprägten sterbeprozess
verbunden sind
das ist das bild das viele vor sich
haben wenn sie der diskussion um
sterbehilfe folgen und sich daran
beteiligen
die regelungen die wir aber als
gesetzgeber treffen müssen müssen auch
für ganz andere situationen gute
lösungen seien
für menschen beispielsweise die unter
depressionen leiden die akute sie
überwältigende sorge oder trauer spüren
die unter finanziellen problemen leiden
die suchterkrankungen durchleiden und
für menschen die anderen in bestimmten
lebenssituationen nicht zur last fallen
wollen
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen wie
würden wir denken wenn es um unseren
bruder wenn es um unsere schwester ging
um unseren sohn unserer tochter die
einen sterbewunsch in ihrem herzen trägt
sicher niemand möchte seinen nächsten im
sterben leiden sehen und niemand darf
ein sterbewunsch per gesetz verbieten
und das will hier auch niemand und die
band will den sterbewilligen
kriminalisieren
aber ich bin mir auch sicher dass wir
uns alle wünschen würden dass der
sterbewunsch unseres angehörigen
sorgfältig ja sorgfältig überdacht wäre
dass er ohne äußeren druck gefallen wäre
dass ihm vor allen dingen alle
möglichkeiten des auswegs aus der als
ausweglos empfundenen situation bekannt
gemacht worden wären und von ihm mit
bedacht werden konnten
und deshalb liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen ist es so wichtig dass wir
regelungen verabschieden die genau das
auch mit bedenken und mit ermöglichen
deshalb ist es wichtig dass wir ein
gestuftes beratungsverfahren etablieren
das auch sofern der erwartete verlauf
einer krankheit dem nicht entgegensteht
zeit zum überlegen zeit und raum für
neue begegnungen und neue gedanken und
die entwicklung neuer gedanken lässt und
das vor allem
interdisziplinär durch entsprechende
beratungsmöglichkeiten alternativen des
auswege aus der alles ausweglos
empfundenen situation eröffnet und dem
sterbewilligen bekannt gemacht
vielen dank herr hille sowie
als nächster redner das wort sich der
kollege helge lind für die gruppe
herrling plan
und das ist ja die gruppe um den
gesetzentwurf recht auf suizid assistenz
nach beratung mit ungefähr moment 70
unterstützern
präsident sehr geehrte damen und herren
trotz
aus unserer sicht unberechtigte vorwürfe
wir würden mit unserem freiheitlichen
entwurf nicht prävention wollen und
nicht das leben schützen wollen haben
wir bisher denke ich sehr
zurückgenommen zurückhaltend über die
vergangenen monate argumentiert ich
denke aber wir müssen das jetzt
offensiver tun gestern sprach mich ein
taxifahrer an an das war eigentlich die
debatte und die entscheidung über 219 a
aber er brauche ich auch an auf den
assistierten suizid den er befürwortet
er berichtete von einer 90 jährigen frau
aus einer entfernten nachbarschaft die
nachdem ihr mann verstorben war sie auch
schwer krank war wie schwer es ist nicht
klar
sich ein sperrte das mitteilte und zu
tode hungerte
wie gehen wir damit um wenn wir
beratungsmöglichkeiten haben wie wir es
vorsehen besteht die möglichkeit dass
sich diese grausame form nicht
wiederholt aber wir haben keine
gewissheit dass sie sich anders
entschieden hätte wenn
wir entsprechende beratung anbieten
bestünde auch die möglichkeit ja die
chance mit umfassender aufklärung dass
sie sich eben fürs leben entschieden
hätte und nicht für den tod aber wir
wissen es nicht wir können das nicht
gewähren und wir wollen das auch nicht
gewähren und sicherstellen können denn
wir müssen am ende akzeptieren dass der
moment sein kann dass jemand
selbstbestimmt aus motiven über die er
oder sie selbst entscheidet sich
entscheidet aus dem leben zu gehen
und das müssen wir möglich und wir
müssen es auch assistiert ermöglichen
das hat uns das verfassungsgericht
aufgegeben
ich erinnere auch an einen
beeindruckenden bericht in der
frankfurter allgemeinen sonntagszeitung
über die familie des ehemaligen berliner
staatssekretär ist mark rackles der mit
seinen geschwistern melanie und jennifer
die eltern sind ja und rolf über jahre
begleitet hat am ende gingen sie
gemeinsam in den suizid
das ist kein
romantisierende und kann dämonisieren
bericht er macht zwei dinge deutlich die
geschwister und das war für sie ein
schweres regen sind am ende immer noch
der meinung dass es richtig war zu
begleiten auf diesem weg trotz allem
aber vor allem wird an diesem bericht
deutlich wenn sie den sich angucken dass
wir in unserer gesellschaft gegenwärtig
uns nicht darauf verstehen und kein weg
gefunden haben um zu gehen mit menschen
die die entscheidung treffen wollen am
ende auch treffen sich zu wünschen mit
unterstützung selbst gewählt ihr leben
zu beenden
das ist eine große leerstelle und wir
haben die debatte seit dem
verfassungsgerichtsurteil wenn wir
ehrlich sind nicht breit und nicht
gesellschaftlich geführt aber wir hätten
das tun müssen in dieser form
deshalb ist für uns folgendes klar wir
halten den weg über das strafgesetzbuch
über das strafrecht nicht für dankbar
und für grundlegend falsch
verhalten es auch
nicht für richtig
ein werbeverbot über 1 217 a
nachgebildet nach dem 219 a den wir ja
vorhin verabschiedet habe im sinne einer
aushebung das so zu erlassen und wir
halten es für sinnvoll in dem zentrum
das vertrauliche verhältnis von arzt
ärztin und person zu stellen und sind
noch nicht überzeugt und sehen auch
probleme in der abgrenzung zwischen
medizinische notlage und anderen
situation weil eben auch das
verfassungsgericht deutlich gemacht hat
dass wir nicht über motive bericht
nahmen das nicht fremd definierte
kategorien materielle kategorien
entscheidend sein dürfen zudem ist seine
abgrenzungsfragen vor allem aber stelle
ich folgende frage was für ein
menschenbild und gesellschaftsbild haben
werden es ist doch nicht so dass wir uns
in einem verrechnungs verhältnis bewegen
von palliativmedizin von hospizbewegung
von prävention und assistierten suizid
nein zusammen ist das zu denken und
wieso wieso gehen wir oft davon aus dass
menschen auch wenn uns das nicht gefällt
auch wenn wir uns dagegen wehren am ende
auch wenn es sozial nicht angemessen sei
markt eine solche entscheidung treffen
sie auch treffen können und wir deshalb
nicht von unserer eigenen befindlichkeit
ausgehen können sondern diese zutiefst
persönliche entscheidung in ihrer
persönlichen form wahrnehmen und sehen
müssen und dabei unterstützen denjenigen
die es entscheiden auch wenn sie nicht
entschädigen erschienen sind das
unterstützung beraten aber auch
denjenigen die helfen sie nicht in die
gefahr der strafbarkeit zu senden und
deshalb ist es aus meiner sicht
notwendig auch in diesem moment an
jemanden zu erinnern der leider uns
verlassen hatte nämlich peter hintze der
vor vier jahren in einem glaube ich sehr
eindrucksvollen statement als
wuppertaler abgeordneter der cdu
folgendes gesagt hat wir wollen dass am
sterbebett nichts staatsanwälte stehen
sondern angehörige und ärzte und wir
wollen mit unserem entwurf sage ich für
uns alle dass
ärzte und ärztin dass angehörige das
betroffene die entschieden sind oder
auch noch rim mit ihrer entscheidung
dass wir sie nicht allein lassen dass
ihr leben geschützt wird dass sie aber
auch in ihrem gewissen und ihrer
freiheit zu entscheiden und ihrer
selbstbestimmung die für uns eine
ansteht eine zumutung ist die wir aber
aushalten und ertragen müssen ja wir
müssen ist dass wir ihm beistehen genau
das wollen sie hier und deshalb bitten
wir um ihre unterstützung vielen dank
sagt haye gelingt und hat noch mal
geworben für den gesetzentwurf rund um
die gruppe von katrin helling klar und
anderen die das unterstützt und jetzt
hören wir die nächste rednerin das ist
kirsten kaputt kontert
von den grünen
herr präsident liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen heute geht es ja tatsächlich um
die großen um die letzten um sehr
persönliche fragen die wir alle ganz
individuell beantworten müssen sowohl
hier im parlament wie auch im leben die
nähere ich mich eigentlich diesem
unfassbaren gedanken dass wir alle zum
tode hin leben wie die ich denn damit um
wenn ich selbst oder personen in meinem
umfeld nicht mehr leben wollen und
suizidalität ist häufig fast alle
menschen kennen diese gedanken in der
pubertät in lebenskrisen im alter
suizidale gedanken sind volatil
und sie entstehen immer immer im kontext
der lebensbedingungen und unserer
beziehung so persönlich dieses thema
also ist so relevant ist es wie wir als
gesellschaft damit umgehen
ich halte es für elementar und das sage
ich aufgrund meiner langjährigen
erfahrung als fachärztin für psychiatrie
und psychotherapie
dass wir das thema suizidalität
enttabuisieren wir müssen es aushalten
zu lassen menschen ermutigen über ihre
gefühle zu sprechen und das senkt das
suizidrisiko
suizidalität ist nämlich meistens nicht
der wunsch nach dem tod sondern der
wunsch nach einer pause von einer als
unerträglich empfundenen lebenssituation
und wenn diese drucksituationen
nachlassen dann verschwindet oft auf der
suizidalen pult und innere druck sie
aktionen sind eine psychische erkrankung
oder auch das gefühl überflüssig zu sein
oder anderen nicht zur last fallen zu
wollen äußere drucksituationen sind
beispielsweise mangelnde pflege aber
auch armut oder überschuldung und ich
finde es ist eine gesellschaftliche
diskussion wenn wir sagen machen wir den
zugang zum assistierten suizid leichter
als andere hilfen erreichbar zu machen
es ist also liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen unsere zentrale
gesellschaftliche aufgabe
suizidprävention auszubauen das fordert
im übrigen ja auch der ärztetag mit
ihrem beschluss im schönen bremen als
interfraktionelle gruppe von
abgeordneten aller demokratischer
fraktionen legen wir damit darum also
gemeinsam mit unserem gesetzentwurf zur
regulierung des assistierten suizids
gleichzeitig einen antrag für mehr
prävention vor
das bundesverfassungsgericht hat
geurteilt der zugang zu assistierten
suizid muss möglich sein und die
autonomie muss gesichert werden und das
gesicht erwischt hat klargestellt dass
der gesetzgeber mit einem schutzkonzept
genau diese frei verantwortlichkeit
absichern kann und das gericht hat klar
gestellt dass gefahr trächtige angebote
des assistierten suizid verboten werden
dürfen und genau darum geht es meiner
truppe die suizid assistenz zu
ermöglichen aber nicht zu fördern und
die autonomie eben gerade zu sichern
durch ein schutzkonzept damit der wille
tatsächlich frei verantwortlich und von
dauer gebildet ist
und unser gesetzentwurf bild das
strafrecht
um eine möglichst widerspruchsfreie
gesetzgebung zu ermöglichen wir erwarten
von denen die die suizid assistenz
anbieten dass sie sicherstellen dass die
hilfesuchenden wirklich autonom handeln
dass hier die frei verantwortlichkeit
gesichert ist und
dafür definieren wir klare kriterien das
psychiatrische gespräch wartefristen ein
mehr augen prinzip
und das der assistierte suizid bei
kindern und jugendlichen ausgeschlossen
ist und den übrigen regeln auch die
schweiz die niederlande ihre suizid
assistenz im strafrecht dahinter sollten
wir nicht zurückfallen es taucht ihr
auch immer mal das argument auf auch
heute hier in der debatte ein breiter
zugang zum assistierten suizid erspare
den menschen und beispielsweise auch
lokführern die schrecklichen harten
suizide aber das ist falsch
die harten suizide verringern sich nicht
durch angebote des assistierten suizid
stattdessen werden aber andere
bevölkerungsgruppen womöglich zum suizid
hin geführt deswegen steigen die zahlen
in ländern mit leichteren zugang zum
assistierten suizid beispielsweise in
belgien in der schweiz in oregon die
schleichende normalisierung ich halte
die für ein problem
es ist eine gefahr wenn wir alten
kranken armen menschen womöglich
vermitteln sie seien überflüssig
insbesondere die modelle die eine art
staatliches gütesiegel für angebote des
assistierten suizids voll sehen und das
sollten wir verhindern niemand soll in
unserem land wirklich niemand soll das
gefühl bekommen nicht gewollt zu sein
nehmen wir also das urteil des
bundesverfassungsgerichts ernst
ermöglichen wir den zugang zum
assistierten suizid in klar definierten
bahn und verbessern wir gleichzeitig die
suizidprävention vielen dank
dafür hat hier kirchen und kapert
gontard um unterstützung geworben eine
regelung außerhalb des strafrechtes
möchte ja die gruppe und um renate
künast und andere hier soll betroffenen
sicherer zugang zu bestimmten
betäubungsmitteln eröffnet meine sehr
verehrten damen und herren das
bundesverfassungsgericht hat 2020 ich
denke ein historisches urteil gefällt
wer sterben will darf sich dabei
unterstützen lassen hat es ausgeführt
deshalb haben wir als gruppe einen
gesetzentwurf zum schutz des rechts auf
ein selbstbestimmtes sterben vorgelebt
lukas berner hat einiges auch aus
juristischer sicht schon dazu ausgeführt
unser vorschlag so denke ich schafft
einen recht sicheren weg der das
selbstbestimmungsrecht des einzelnen und
das urteil des bundesverfassungsgericht
tatsächlich umsetzt dabei
unterscheidet unser entwurf zwischen
sterbewilligen die eine medizinische
notlage sind und allen anderen für die
erste krippe gruppe soll es schneller
und einfacher möglich sein
sterbehilfe in anspruch zu nehmen denn
wer
unerträgliche schmerzen hat wer keine
aussicht mehr auf heilung hat soll nicht
übermäßig leiden müssen liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen ja die
palliativmedizin kann das leiden von
todkranken oft wirklich erheblich
mindern aber dürfen wir menschen die
furchtbare qualen erleiden die
zusätzliche möglichkeit des
selbstbestimmten lebens nicht nehmen ich
musste persönlich erleben wie geliebte
menschen mit dem tod ringen
irgendwann bei meiner frau kamen
irgendwann aber meiner mutter die beide
schwer an krebs erkrankt waren klar dass
sie den kampf nicht gewinnen wir in
solchen situationen sollten menschen
sterbehilfe in anspruch nehmen können so
geben wir ihnen autonomie und würde am
lebensende zurück
meine damen und herren
für jene die nicht an einer
medizinischen
notlage sind sieht unser entwurf einen
weg auch zum selbstbestimmten sterben
vor denn diese personen haben ein recht
darauf insbesondere nach der
entscheidung des
bundesverfassungsgerichts
dieser weg soll allen volljährigen
menschen offenstehen die selbstbestimmt
und klar entscheiden können denn
unabhängige beratungsgespräche mit
angemessenen zeitlichen abstand wird die
dauerhaftigkeit des verbundes des
sterbens sichergestellt zudem müssen die
beratungsgespräche zweifelsfrei
feststellen dass eine solche stabile
entscheidung ohne äußeren druck
getroffen wurde dieser aspekt ist mir
deshalb besonders wichtig denn niemand
soll früher aus dem leben scheiden weil
er glaubt anderen zur last zu fallen
mit den beratungsgesprächen wollen wir
menschen die sterben wollen vielmehr
perspektiven aufzeigen perspektiven zum
leben diese beweggründe sollen eine
einladung gerade zum weiterleben seien
eben keine aufforderung zum sterben
meine sehr verehrten damen und herren
wer aber selbst bestimmt aus dem leben
scheiden will dem dürfen wir als
gesellschaft uns nicht in den weg
stellen das möchte ich ausdrücklich
sagen und deshalb muss gelten wer andere
beim sterben unterstützt darf dafür
nicht bestraft werden wie kann jemand
bestraft werden der dabei hilft etwas
nicht verbotenes zu tun fragen ist
das strafrecht das haben wir immer
gelernt jedenfalls
die hier die nicht wenigen die
juristinnen und juristen sind das
strafrecht kann nur die ultima ratio der
gesetzgebung sein das strafrecht kann
und darf nicht für jene gelten die aus
mitgefühl aus menschlichkeit sterbehilfe
leisten meine sehr verehrten damen und
herren liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
ich bin mir sicher das hat auch die
heutige debatte wieder gezeigt dass kein
abgeordnete es sich bei dieser wirklich
existentiellen frage leicht macht wir
alle wollen das leben schützen und wir
alle wollen die würde des einzelnen
achten
mit unserem entwurf mit unseren ruf
unserer gruppe künast schaffen wir ein
gesetz zum schutz des recht auf
selbstbestimmtes sterben schaffen wir
oder schlagen wir vielleicht besser
gesagt einen rechtssicheren vernünftigen
weg vor ein weg der zum
leben ermutigen will aber anerkennt dass
sich menschen auch für den tod
entscheiden dürfen ein weg der
betroffene und hilfe willigen mehr
klarheit und rechtssicherheit gibt
lassen sie uns gemeinsam
einen würdigen und sicheren rahmen für
die sterbehilfe in deutschland finden
dankeschön
franke der rund um den antrag der gruppe
renate künast ein anderer sich
positioniert hat alle werben hier für
einen offenen diskurs keiner macht es
sich einfach das hat die debatte bisher
gezeigt gehören jetzt stefan pischinger
kollegen als noch praktizieren der
hausarzt weiß ich dass die korona
pandemie nicht nur infektions werden
sondern auch wählen der depression wir
unser land hat brechen lassen sätze wie
es ist mir alles zu viel ich habe
einfach keine lust mehr kommen in der
regel von menschen die einen leidvollen
weg hinter sich haben auf depressiv sind
kein aus merken da zu sehen glauben die
ihrem scheinbar unerträglichen leben ein
rasches ende setzen wollen doch wollen
diese menschen das wirklich wenn sie so
reden ist der suizid wirklich der
unbedingte freie und selbstbestimmte
willen derjenigen person die so redet
ist es da nicht angenehm jahr
verführerisch zu wissen dass sterbehilfe
vereine gibt die in einem eine in einer
solchen situation versprechen wir helfen
ihnen den ausklang ihres lebens zu
gestalten oder die ein humanes sterben
in aussicht stellen nach dem motto
selbstbestimmt leben selbstbestimmt
sterben wie es aber tatsächlich um die
selbstbestimmung bei solche sterbehilfen
bestellt ist es tatsächlich das zentrale
attribut bei jedem fall vom begleiteten
suizid ich bezweifle das jedenfalls ist
das
jedenfalls ist selbstbestimmung in
unserem gesetzentwurf das zentrale
leitmotiv um die vom
bundesverfassungsgericht vorgegebene
möglichkeit des assistierten suizid zu
legitimieren das
bundesverfassungsgericht in seinem
urteil vom 26
februar 2020 zwar keine konkreten
materiellen voraussetzungen für die
entscheidung zum suizid betont aber die
entscheidung des präsidenten frei
verantwortlichkeit von dauerhaftigkeit
und innere festigkeit geprägt sein muss
gleichzeitig hat das gericht auch betont
dass der gesetzgeber ein legitimes ziel
verfolgt wenn er verhindern möchte dass
sich assistierter suizid als normale
form der lebens beendigung durchsetzt
und wenn er sicherstellen möchte dass
der folgenreichen schluss des
betroffenen tatsächlich auf einem freien
nicht von äußeren umständen geprägten
bilden beruht das ist der leitgedanke
unseres überfraktionellen gesetzes im
kurs denn
denn zwischen 50 und 90 prozent der
selbstmorde in deutschland stehen nach
auskunft der deutschen gesellschaft für
psychiatrie und psychotherapie in
zusammenhang zwischen erkrankungen die
man auch erfolgreich behandeln und in
den griff bekommen kann wenn man sie
rechtzeitig erkennt und therapiert
insbesondere menschen mit depression
haben nachweislich ein stark erhöhtes
suizidrisiko
menschen die es besonders vor sich
selbst und vor äußeren einflüssen zu
schützen wird die meisten suizidgedanken
sind nach erkenntnissen psychiatrischer
und psychotherapeutischer fachkreise
volatil also kurzfristig situativ
bedingter natur sie sind also ein
weniger ausdruck eines tiefs im punkten
im wunsch es tatsächlich zu sterben als
vielmehr die sehnsucht nach einer
auszeit aus einer als unerträglich
empfundenen lebenssituation daher haben
wir eine engmaschige und klar
vorgegebene beratungspflicht mit
bestimmten wartefristen vorgegeben damit
ein möglicherweise doch lösbar und
temporärer zustand nicht vorschnell zu
einer irreversiblen entscheidung für die
selbsttötung werden kann nach jetzigem
recht steht den stempel vereinen türen
tor offen die betroffenen schnell
vermeintlich zu erlösen das können und
dürfen wir so nicht stehen lassen meine
damen und herren daher ist die regelung
im strafgesetzbuch auch die einzig
wirksame dieses gesetzgeberische lösung
um missbrauch zu verhindern und menschen
vor falschen äußeren einflüssen zu
schützen wird diese selbstbestimmung und
damit die würde des einzelnen menschen
missachtet handelt zutiefst kriminelle
muss entsprechend strafrechtlich belangt
werden können liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen ein erkenntnis des urteils des
bundesverfassungsgerichts wollen wir die
suizid assistenz ermöglichen sie aber
nicht fördern ältere und
schutzbedürftige sowie von schweren
persönlichen schicksalsschlägen
gepeinigte menschen müssen wir vor
falschen einflüssen schützen deshalb ist
auch dass die sie zur prävention auf
allen ebenen wichtig so wie wir sie in
unserem begleitet antrag fordern meine
damen und herren
wie das bundesverfassungsgericht sehen
auch wir die autonome selbstbestimmung
eines menschen als unmittelbaren
ausdruck seiner persönlichkeitsrechte in
der sich seine würde als mensch in
seiner individualität und identität und
integrität entfaltet im sinne des
christlichen menschenbildes und der
europäischen aufklärung und unser
gesetzentwurf nach meiner festen
überzeugung am ersten dazu dass die
vorgaben des bundesverfassungsgerichts
beachtet und der mensch als
selbstbestimmtes wesen geachtet aber
auch geschützt wird vielen dank an die
fristen die hier stefan kissinger
angesprochen hat das beispielsweise
zwischen den untersuchungen von
verschiedenen fachärzten mindestens mit
zwischen diesen untersuchungstermin drei
monate liegen sollen und für die dem
entwurf zufolge soll zwischen den
abschließenden untersuchung und der
selbsttötung alle wartefrist von
mindestens zwei wochen ihnen petra sitte
die nächste rednerin ist auch
initiatorin mit initiatorin eines
antrags nur einmal was da so beschwingt
besungen wird ist nur die eine seite der
medaille
man stirbt auch nur einmal also sterben
und tod gehören zum leben sind aber doch
etwas ganz besonderes dass wir gern aus
unserem alltag verbannen entscheidungen
darüber sind stets ausgesprochen
bewegend wir alle müssen sterben aber
normal wird doch der tod deshalb nie und
demzufolge wird es auch der suizid nicht
und nicht die suizidhilfe anders als das
behauptet wird meine damen und herren
man hat versucht sein leben weitgehend
selbstbestimmt zu führen wie es ja auch
immer von uns erwartet wurde warum bitte
soll man bei der sterbe entscheidung
damit aufhören auch über das ende des
eigenen lebens wollen menschen selbst
entscheiden und sie sollen es selbst
entscheiden können und das
bundesverfassungsgericht hat uns
ausdrücklich aufgegeben das war ja für
viele überraschend keine unterscheidung
zwischen
krankheitsbedingten wunsch auf
suizidhilfe und an motiven zu treffen
und tatsächlich ist es doch so dass
menschen abwägen dass wir uns gedanken
machen dass rat gesucht wird das
austausch gesucht wird niemand trifft
derlei entscheidung leichtfertig viele
betroffene fühlen sich geradezu
überfordert aber guten freunden oder
angehörigen geht es doch nicht anders
sterben ist bei weitem nicht nur ein
medizinisches problem wenngleich es auch
darüber eine aufklärung bedarf aber ich
will dass ausdrücklich auch mit sagen es
bietet sich ein in unsere konkreten
lebensverhältnisse wie frei kann man
denn in altersarmut entscheiden das
gehört auch zur suizidprävention
zudem
zudem geht es um eine ebenso
individuelle wie soziale ja
psychosoziale entscheidung man löst sich
schließlich von menschen man löst sich
vom leben und daher soll eine beratung
geboten werden welche ergebnisoffen
geführt wird und die alle optionen in
der ein wie in der anderen richtung zur
sprache bringt darum geht es entgegen
mancher am mancher behauptungen in
unserem gesetz ausdrücklich es geht um
prävention es geht um aufklärung über
alle fragen und es geht um alternativen
bleibt es dann doch beim sterbewunsch
geht es darum diesen sicher und ebenso
würde voll umsetzen zu können bislang
war genau das nahezu unmöglich obwohl es
anderslautende gerichtliche entscheidung
gab nicht zuletzt sogar vom
bundesverfassungsgericht
blieb also nur dass man sich für hohe
summen von sterbehilfe vereinen
begleiten ließ oder auch in einer
grauzone von sterbehelfer das ist doch
nicht akzeptabel obwohl deutschland fast
150 jahre
suizidhilfe ungeregelt gelassen hat
hatte niemanden legalen zugang zu einem
entsprechenden medikament was für ein
widerspruch und wir sind verpflichtet
diesen widerspruch aufzulösen
wir wollen aber zunächst kostenfreie und
kompetente beratung bevor ein arzt nach
weitere medizinische aufklärung das
medikament verschreiben kann es sei an
dieser stelle noch mal ausdrücklich
betont kein arzt keine ärztin soll dazu
verpflichtet werden meine damen und
herren über
unserem konzept über unser konzept
werden kompetente und unparteiliche
hilfe und beratung allen kostenlos
zugänglich die eigene soziale situation
kann also niemanden bei der suche nach
hilfe und beratung begrenzen niemand
soll mit seiner entscheidung allein
gelassen werden aber jeder und jedem
soll sie als letzte lösung offen stehen
auch sterben gehört zu einem
selbstbestimmten lebens weg bis dann
petra sitte ist mitinitiatorin des
antrags rund um die gruppe auch von
katrin helling klar der im moment
ungefähr 70 abgeordneten und unterstützt
wird aber die meinungsbildung ist ja
noch lange nicht abgeschlossen letzter
redner jetzt zu diesem
tagesordnungspunkt ist benjamin strasser
er unterstützt den antrag rund um die
gruppe von lars castellucci überhaupt
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen das
bundesverfassungsgericht hat mit seinem
urteil aus dem februar 2020
rechtsgeschichte geschrieben es hat zum
ersten mal ein recht auf selbstbestimmte
sterben manifestiert und das auch
richtig niemand hat das recht darüber zu
entscheiden ob das leben eines anderen
noch lebenswert ist oder nicht einen
positiven im negativen und deshalb ist
unsere gruppe die rechtliche und die
tatsächliche durchsetzung der
selbstbestimmung von allen menschen in
allen lebenslagen so wichtig das
bundesverfassungsgericht es wird aber
nicht an dieser feststellung auf anders
als manche debattenbeiträge im parlament
und in der öffentlichkeit vermuten
lassen ist es eben nicht so dass es sich
damit begnügt dieses recht festzustellen
denn ob wir es wollen oder nicht ihr
alle leben in beziehung unser wille ist
geprägt von den erfahrungen die wir im
leben machen aber auch von haltungen und
werden andere von unserem sozialen
umfeld und deshalb war es den
richterinnen und richtern des
verfassungsgerichts eben auch wichtig
dass wir als gesetzgeber die aufgabe
haben die tatsächliche autonomie des
suizidwilligen bestmöglich zu schützen
und auch dieser leitlinie folgt unser
gesetzesentwurf liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen ich glaube wir müssen darüber
sprechen dass sterbe wünsche endlich
enttabuisiert werden wir müssen uns als
gesellschaft mit ihnen auseinandersetzen
denn die praxis zeigt dass oftmals wenn
betroffene den satz äußern ich will
nicht mehr leben nach einer
auseinandersetzung nach einem
ernsthaften gespräch mit ihnen der satz
verstanden muss als ich will nicht mehr
leben die betroffenen wollen sich
befreien aus einer situation die sie
persönlich als nicht mehr lebenswert
empfinden und das zeigt der grat
zwischen einem dauerhaften und
ernsthaften suizid wunsch und einem
hilferuf an die gesellschaft er ist
schmal liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
ich möchte nicht in einer gesellschaft
leben in der hilfe rufe verhallen oder
mit achselzucken zur kenntnis genommen
werden und deswegen ist es kern unseres
gesetzesentwurf dass eine umfassende
beratungspflicht sichergestellt wird
über die alternativen zum assistierten
suizid die menschen in einer solchen
lage ihnen muss bewusst sein welche
andere möglichkeiten es gibt um sich aus
einer solchen von ihnen als nicht mehr
lebenswert empfundenen situationen zu
befreien und dieses auch zeigen das ist
doch keine bevormundung oder kein auf
zwingende eigenen moral des eigenen
willens sondern ist der kampf rechte
selbstbestimmung für wahlfreiheit wenn
ich weiß welche alternativen ich habe
und diese alternativen müssen dann aber
auch tatsächlich und zeitnah zur
verfügung stehen liebe kollegen und
kollegen deswegen sind wir auch der
einzelnen die einzige gruppe die einen
eigenen antrag zur suizidprävention
erarbeitet hat auch das gehört zusammen
und ich möchte an der stelle auch noch
sagen manche debattenbeiträge
insbesondere in der orientierungs
debatte aber auch in der öffentlichkeit
in den letzten monaten haben mich
wirklich irritiert da wird
beispielsweise behauptet das urteil des
verfassungsgerichts verbiete es zitat
über eine strafrechtliche lösung
überhaupt nur nachzudenken
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen es ist
das verfassungsgericht in seinem urteil
dass uns als gesetzgeber ausdrücklich
ermöglicht dass wir diese frage wieder
im strafrecht regeln es ist das
bundesverfassungsgericht das in seinem
urteil davon spricht dass von einer
normalisierung des assistierten suizid
sowie dem angebot der geschäftsmäßigen
suizid assistenz eine gefahr für die
selbstbestimmung des einzelnen ausgeht
und deswegen ist die frage relevant
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen wie wir
ein beratungs und schutzkonzept dass wir
ja offensichtlich alle wollen in der
praxis auch so umsetzen dass es gelebt
wird und dass es nicht nur im
bundesgesetzblatt städten deswegen ist
für unsere gruppe klar wer sich erlaubt
über ein gesetzlich vorgeschriebenes
beratungsverfahren hinwegzusetzen und
damit in unzulässiger weise in die
selbstbestimmung anderer einzugreifen
der muss mit strafrechtlichen
konsequenzen
das ist keine kriminalisierung von
sterbewilligen das ist auch keine
kriminalisierung herr kollege frank von
menschen die hilfe leisten weil zum
suizid im rahmen eines beratungskonzept
sondern es ist die konsequente umsetzung
des auftrags des
bundesverfassungsgerichts nämlich die
selbstbestimmung von allen menschen in
allen lebenslagen tatsächlich
tatsächlich zu sichern vielen herzen
[Applaus]